you said that a harmless man is not a
good man A Good Man is a very dangerous
man who has that under voluntary control
how should people become more dangerous
becoming more articulate that's the
primary array of weapons physical
prowess is something and it's not
nothing that physical confidence that
comes along with that as well but the
same thing replicated at the level of
the ability to communicate and think
that's way broader field of battle and
opportunity this is one thing that isn't
taught well especially to boys partly
because they're less obedient partly
because they're less agreeable so what
do you tell disagreeable boys there's
nothing that makes you more formidable
than verbal competence that's part of
the reason that rap artists are so
popular especially among disaffected
young men black and white light because
they're unbelievably articulate they
have this incredible verbal prowess it's
unbelievably attractive you know and
it's associated with genuine artistic
and Redemptive activity often focusing
on something that's approximately the
voice of the underclass let's say but a
powerful voice right